[Music]
today on the dish a taste of Northern
Italy by way of New York City's flat
iron District thanks to Chef Stefano
seki back in 2019 seki opened resdora
his take on the foods of the Amelia
romagna region of Italy he'd been eating
since childhood a three-star New York
Times review would follow and a Michelin
star in 2021 and while that's made one
of resdora's 60 seats awfully hard to
get the accolades haven't changed what
you'll find once you get there a
restaurant built on tradition with a
chef who's woven a story into every bite
Jeff
Stephanie is
his brother New York new Italian
restaurant
we don't take ourselves very serious but
we take you know what we do very serious
and possibly being really important for
us all homemade everything yep
at resdora which Loosely translates to
Nona or grandmother yeah
he's brought a piece of them and Italy
to New York
this is one of those raccoons that I
mean with the known as Australia juicy
many times like Lord Miranda and it's
one of those things that
you just want to kind of sit and think
about it right no I want to eat more no
I don't want to no question I want
anymore all right the taliolini served
with Ragu mode is one of around two
dozen pastas on the resdora menu
with seki leading diners on a
gastronomic journey through the Amelia
romagna region of Italy you need to grab
a Yoko Frito because these are still
piping hot you have Mortadella there do
I just take a bite of this yeah here's
what I do it's gonna be messy it's hot
but you want to fold it over like this
and then and like a nice little pot of
Brava
that's good I was lucky enough to get a
private tour a lot of the dishes are
just based on like memories that I have
either growing up going to Italia and or
working there like these black truffle
Lobster gerasole we used to go to Remini
and we used to take the train there and
you see sunflowers on the way and what
would you eat you'd eat soup Seafood
right it literally is that's a little
Sunfish so the idea is you have that
black truffle with the beautiful Lobster
and a little bit of lobster stock to
make the sauce I love that it's a little
work of art too
there was also that wovo raviolo di Nino
burguesse a tribute to the chef who made
the original dish famous in the region
this seasonal variation is topped with
white truffle and brown butter filled
with ricotta and egg yolk s it's like a
farm fresh egg inside and it's dark
orange like we have the best eggs you
can get your hands on you have worked
tirelessly to get these eggs eight nine
months to figure out how to get the
right eggs where we actually get them
from the south now believe it or not
from Arkansas
guys put it order fire yeah seki calls
the gramina gialloe Verde the sleeper
served with slow braised sausage Ragu
and Bianco far more decadent is
resdora's contemporary version of
Angelini filled with 24 month old
prosciutto prosciutto Mortadella and
pork shoulder topped with parmigiano
sauce with the signature cheese also
aged for two years and for us finished
with a century-old a Cheto balsamico
well that balsamic
it just brings out a flavor I'm gonna
give you another one because you're
going to ask me for another one no I'm
just going to reach over and take that
one because you're kidding that works
too
and then there's the one dish seki says
he can never take off the menu Grandma
walking through forest in Amelia based
off Sundays spent eating at the homes of
local no nuts it's cappelletti pasta
with braised and sauteed leeks
parmigiano and a porcini mushroom base
this knowing that we saw in her backyard
and find like porcini and she would
roast porcini bracelets and then we'd
make this capletti's based off the
Romania region in Romania those are you
know memories you put together they call
how do you find a wedding incorporate
and tell the story how do you make that
story into a pasta has she ever had this
pasta I'm trying to get her to come over
come over can you tell it can you like
no no please come over
how much fun is it for you
to create these taste memories
amazing right I mean your eyes just said
it if you're going to do this
has a job then then you should probably
just be all in if not then why do it I
think you've got a second course
together yeah seki grew up in Texas one
of three kids born to Immigrant parents
including an Italian father while they
ran a restaurant and sent him back to
Italy each summer seki says he didn't
always see food as his calling my
parents had me working really early I
would be like basketball football
practice or baseball or whatever and
then like I would have to go right to
work I could never finish practice and
like that makes you bitter I mean I'm
gonna be honest and like you don't see
that back then but now I I can't think
my parents enough he says it all changed
when he graduated high school enrolled
in The Culinary Institute of America and
moved to New York City I interned
externed in the city here cooking and
that's when I when I was finally around
places where people were like really
taking it serious is when I got fired up
and then
I was eating around a lot and I still
never tasted the food that I'd eat in
Italians for so long so so that's where
he headed living in Modena for the next
three years learning his craft from both
nonas and Masters you should pay homage
to these people that have been doing it
for so long and so well and respect it
you should learn how the basics are done
we talk about contemporary pasta or a
classic pasta gramina talulini I knew
you need to an extent these are the
classics right and so learn how the
classics are done and then you can be
contemporary and find ways to like work
speaking of that jira Soleil Chef was
kind enough to give me a quick lesson in
creating the restora favorite see where
there's an edge pinch and well I didn't
exactly show his promise mine's not
looking as pretty as yours how many
points
takes an obvious pride in the Traditions
he learned
lots of Beauty look at that
and continues to pass on be it by touch
or taste
life is short when you find out what you
want to do you start becoming obsessed
with it things become pretty cool is
that where you are right now I hope yeah
I mean I'm obsessed and pretty cool yeah
yeah yeah Dana it's the best business
your job is to make people happy every
day
putting food in people's mouths where
people were like oh my God like you're
out of the kitchen and you're in the
dining room and you're just watching
like customers talk to each other and
they didn't even say word and they just
shake their head and smile that's all
you need right that's our job is to make
people happy I mean it's crazy but
that's cool it's incredibly cool
yeah
and you taste that in every bite
obviously we brought you a couple
samplings here and I gotta tell you
think about this when we were there 27
pastas across the menus they're only 60
seats in the restaurants I mean it's
just insane absolutely insane I love how
much he loves his job right yeah and the
tradition behind it learn from the nonas
the grandmothers know they know what do
we have there again on the table so
Grandma walking through the forest in
Amelia I'm sorry now I'm talking with a
mouthful and the gramina Verde that
that's this and the green and yellow
pasta It's supposed to be like the hay
it's got the uh so I believe it's a slow
roasted sausage Ragu that's with it
and the idea is that he was telling me
it's like the transition from Winter to
Spring in the color of all of it great
job just absolutely delicious really
cool yeah all right thanks Dana